- As you all know, there
is a global situation
going on that affects the whole world.
And of course, people
looking for jobs are affected
in a significant way right now as well.
Most companies around the globe
have moved their recruiting
efforts to online formats.
This is also true for consulting,
where the case studies,
behavioral interviews,
and other problem-solving games
now all take place in the online world.
And this of course,
poses some new challenges to candidates.
In this video, I'm going to share
how the recruiting processes
of MBB Consulting Firms,
this stands for McKinsey, BCG, Bain,
but also other tier one,
tier two, consulting firms
do look like at the moment.
For that I talked to several friends
who had interviews in these
firms in the last month
and also did a little Instagram
survey where I got lots
of other impressions from people
literally around the world.
So I'm first going to
describe how these interviews
look like at the moment,
but then also sharing a
couple of tips and tricks.
What you can do to better
adapt to the situation,
hopefully improve your performance
in these interviews as much as possible.
So welcome to another coffee
break here on my channel,
"Firm Learning", my name is
Heinrich and on my channel
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
Though before we start, I
wanna make the disclaimer
that even within the same
firm, interview processes
can change significantly
country by country,
also office by office within one country.
So as always, take this
information with a grain of salt,
though I do believe that there
are some valuable lessons
to be learned for most people applying
to consulting in these special times.
So let's start not all.
What many people reported is that most
of these consulting firms now
apply two tiered approach.
They have some kind of
automated assessment going on
as a first step, and then
they conduct the more
well known regular
interviews as a second step
in some type of telephone or
video conference based format.
So let's jump into both of
these types, one after the other
and then let me share some
insights on them as well.
So let's start with your
automated online assessment.
Almost all of these consulting
firms have some kind
of digital tests like this going on.
It's already pretty well known
as the McKinsey Problem Solving Game
where based on their information,
they ask you to balance out an ecosystem.
Pretty much check how
well you can interact
with information presented
in tables and other forms
and a similar but maybe a
bit more traditional approach
is what BCG is doing
with their interactive online case.
This again is where we will need
to answer different questions
but more in a case-based format,
which more closely resembles
the case interviews
that you also known
from the main interviews
that you will then face
in the second step.
So several people ask me,
"Okay, Heinrich, what can
I do to prepare for that?"
This is not even the standard case format,
what can I really do there?
Isn't much material out there.
And one type of prep
material that I found really
helpful for these types
of online assessments
is the GMAT Integrated
Reasoning Materials.
So for the uninitiated
integrated reasoning
as a section of the GMAT test,
GMAT is a big standardized
computer-based test
that is needed for almost
all MBA programs to get admitted to them.
And in this integrated reasoning section
you get different little
problems with graphs, with charts
which other information
that is presented to you.
And then you are asked
to answer multiple choice
based questions based on these materials.
And from everything
that I've seen or heard,
this is exactly the type of format
that is used by many of
these consulting firms.
So if you are looking
for some widely available prep formats,
check out the Integrated
Reasoning Section of the GMAT,
you will find lots of books
on these topics online.
So trust this can be helpful for you.
The next point that many
people underestimate is
the time pressure that many
of these tests put you into.
So often it's not the case
that you have open-ended time
but in the program, there
is a timer that runs down.
And once the timer is at zero,
you will not be able to
answer any more questions.
And of course as most of these tests
are multiple choice, you should
make sure that you get on to the very end,
because of, for instance
there are four answer options available
in the multiple choice.
Then just, if you are guessing in the end
you still will be able to get
25% of the points, 25% right.
So really do some time management.
So practice this as well again here
the GMAT prep material
can be really helpful
because there is where you
have these time-based tests.
So make sure that at
some point you might just
accept to lose on a
question just to move on
because you do want to avoid
of spending all your time
on one of many, many questions
that you need to answer.
And last year on the
online assessment section,
always look out for little
traps that they put out for you,
because of course they also want to test
how accurate you can think under pressure.
So I've seen how many of these heads
rather are some little traps included.
So for instance, you might be
required to multiply a number
with a certain percentage figure.
And then this percentage
figure is stated as 0.03%.
So I'd assume that many people would
just take the number
and multiply it by 0.03,
because they believe that if they do that,
they are multiplying it with 3%.
But of course it's the
number is stated is 0.03%,
then you need to divide this number
by an additional hundred to actually
be able to multiply it correctly.
So again, these little
things might seem obvious
but if you're under time
pressure looking at these tasks
this would exactly be the
things that you will miss.
Another thing that I've seen is
that maybe there was
one number given to you,
maybe the cost of the
business in one year.
And then there were lots
of information given
from what you needed to calculate the cost
of the business in the
other year, the next year
but then they didn't ask you
for the cost of the next year,
but they asked to for the difference
between the cost of the
first and the second year.
So pretty much needed
to calculate the cost
for the second year and then subtract
the cost from the first year.
And here again, I just
see with lots of people
will just insert the total
cost for the second year
just because they were under pressure.
Didn't read that accurately.
So always take the time to
really precisely understand
what you really need to calculate, to not
make these little mistakes
that then cost you the points
even though you're actually
were on the right track,
you actually had all the numbers
maybe did all the calculations correct,
but just messed up by
just answering precisely,
what was being asked from you.
So these are these
automated online assessments
which now get more and more popular
with these consulting firms,
but then it is all the firms that I heard
of still also conduct interviews person
by person and these take
place via video call
most of the time.
Now I heard of a couple of instances when
the first round also was
a telephone interview.
And I also heard of instances
where the case interviews
is conducted on the telephone.
So I personally believe
that this is quite crazy
because if you cannot even
look somebody in the eye
this is really difficult,
but this might happen to you.
But then at least for the second round
for the more serious interviews,
there will be video calls.
So most of them would
offer taking place on Zoom,
but I have also heard of these interviews
taking place on WebEx,
on Teams or whatever,
but here you can trust it
and the company will provide
the required infrastructure
for you to be able to join.
And then in these interviews,
all of these MBB consulting firms continue
to use the two main interview types
which are also used in the part.
And this is of course
first the case interview.
So I will try to solve the case
that the interview is presenting for you.
And then second, the behavioral part
or personal impact part or
personal experience part
or whatever the different names are
that these companies come up for that.
And this is the interview
we are confronted
with specific situations
that might've happened
in your life.
We are supposed to tell some stories how
you handle these situations in the past
and then they will evolve
for conversation around that.
So here the bottom line is
that this interview part
still is very similar
to how things were before the
current situation evolved.
So if you want to prepare for that
look up all the information
that you find readily available
on the internet, on how
to win in case interviews,
how to win in behavioral interviews.
This will still be very
much applicable, but still
I want to share two considerations
that are really special
about this online interview
video conference format.
And the first is that of course,
because you're not sitting face to face
in a room, it would be much more difficult
to show the interviewer your notes
because this is a common
tactic, especially
in case interviews to
make a very visual drawing
off your structure of the case
and then show it to the interviewer
and then have a discussion
based on your notes.
This of course will be very difficult.
So you might try whether
you can maybe hold it
in your webcam or based on the quality
of your webcam and also
how well the order focuses.
It is very likely that this
will not really work away
that you will not be
really be able to show
your notes to the interviewer.
So what this means is
that you need to be even
more deliberate, even more
salient, even more clear
and transparent about what
your thought processes.
So guide the interviewer
through your thoughts,
really explain him the structure,
you need to put even
more emphasis on this.
Then you might need to put
in a face-to-face interview
because you do not have the chance to show
the interviewer the notes anymore.
And then the next advice
that I have, and here
especially if you know
you have a whole set
of interviews lined up for
the next weeks a month.
Really try to invest into your
video conferencing equipment.
You would be surprised how many candidates
will sit there just with an old laptop
an old built-in webcam in the
laptop of not even full HD.
And then also not really
using a proper microphone
but just the built-in mic
that comes with your laptop.
So while this might work and I trust
many people will also
be able to get offers
with such an equipment.
One way to show your
professionalism, at least
on a subconscious level for the
interviewer, is to make sure
that you really have a good picture,
that you really have professional
audio, professional sound.
So here, if you are
willing to invest a couple
of hundred bucks, this might be worthwhile
if you have a whole set of
interviews now lined up.
I would encourage you to
first upgrade your audio.
I believe the audio will be
the most important factor
driving your impression,
and you can get some very decent USB mics
which are pretty much plug
and play 400 bucks or below.
And then second if you
are willing to invest
a little bit more, try to get
at least the full HD webcam.
And if you have a good incurrent DSLR,
there are different options
to also use your DSLR
also mirror less camera as a webcam.
And this of course would significantly
increase your picture quality.
And the third tip to
really improve your picture
with simple means is lighting.
Even bad cameras will
always look much better,
if you have good lighting.
Here again for 50 bucks or
so you could get yourself
a nice ring light one that I also
have here in front of me.
This will put great light on you
and this will significantly improve
the picture output that you have.
And again, if you do all this
the interviewer will notice it.
Here's one candidate after each other,
all of them with crappy
audio, crappy video,
you know you suddenly
sitting there like a pro,
this will make some kind of impression.
This will show that you're serious
and that you have a professional mindset
when approaching these
types of situations.
So hope that this was helpful
and insightful as always.
If you have any questions,
leave me a comment below
in the comment section,
I will do my very best
to answer every single
comment that you write.
And as you know every comment helps me
with the YouTube algorithm.
So it's very much appreciated to hear
from you guys, let me
know where I can help.
And then if you took any
value out of this video
at all please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to my channel
to stay up to date on all my content.
I also have a mailing list.
You can sign up to that
via the link in the video description.
And if you want to see even more from me,
you also follow me on Instagram,
my handle is @firmlearning.
And I've also invited you
to reach out on LinkedIn.
Again, link to my Linked below
in the video description,
let's get in touch.
I'd love to hear from you.
And I want to say thank you to all
the members of Firm Learning.
You're really making a difference
for this channel for the course.
Thank you so much.
And if you want to become a
member as well and get access
to some member only perks, hit
the join button next to
the subscribe button.
So if you watched until the end,
let me know below in the comments
just that I know this is
very much appreciated.
I'm releasing videos every
single week on Saturdays
and sometimes even some
additional bonus videos.
So very much looking forward
to talk to you again here
in one week until then
good weekend to all of you.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.
Bye bye. Cheers guys.